♪ ♪ ♪
- Un immeuble à bureaux comme
les autres, si ce n'est qu'ici,
il y a une porte pour aller
travailler et une autre
pour dormir et manger.
- C'est là que je dors après.
Là, j'ai le petit rideau de
séparation afin de me permettre
d'être un peu d'être tranquille,
d'être un peu dans mon univers.
puis un peu plus de six
mois, Fortune Obame vit
dans les locaux de cette agence
de communication de Nantes.
Sans domicile, il a ce qu'il
lui faut ici : lit, salle de
bain et cuisinette, notamment.
Lorsqu'ils sont vides,
le soir et les fin de semaines,
ces bureaux ont donc
une autre vocation.
- C'est vraiment super
de pouvoir être, d'avoir
une stabilité et la confiance
d'une équipe et d'un directeur
d'entreprise qui vous laisse
l'accès aux locaux le soir.
Et puis, vous avez une salle
de bain, vous ên, vous ên, vousz
vous. Ça permet de pouvoir être
bien dans sa tête, puis
de se dire : "Là, maintenant,
j'ai un toit. Je ne suis pasobl,
à gauche, selon
le bon vouloir des gens.
C'est Pierre-Yves Loaec
sident de l'entreprise
qui accueille présentement
Fortune qui a eu l'idée
il y a quelques années
de lancer ce projet,nommé les B.
PIERRE-YVES LOAËC
fondateur des Bureaux du coeur
- De croiser une personne
qui dort dehors, alors que
nos bureaux sont chauds.
Il y a une salle de bains,
il y a une douche, il y a
de quoi faire à manger
et mettre un matelas. Ce serait
tellement plus confortable
et l'idée est venue de là.
- Une idée qui s'est rapidement
étendue au-delà des limites
de Nantes.
- Salut, Fortune.
- Les Bureaux du coeur
offrent des hébergements
dans six villes, dont Paris,
et bientôt d'autresmunicipalité.
Évidemment, le projet
à ses limites. Les compagnies
ne peuvent par exemple pas
héberger des familles nombreuses
ou des gens qui ont besoin
de suivis médicaux réguliers.
- On ne résoudra pas
les problèmes d'hébergement
précaires en France avec
les Bureaux du coeur.
Mais les gens qui sont
sur le point de réussir,
on peut vraiment leur mettre
le pied à l'étrier et faciliter
cette réussite et la maximiser,
l'optimiser si on parle
en terconomiquesconomiquesconom.
- Entre employés et personnes
hébergées, la cohabitation
nécessite parfois
une adaptation.
Dans les locaux de l'agence
Nobilito, on assure que
l'expérience est réussie.
- On entend parler de ça
à la télé, discuter pour
de vrai de son parcours
face à face, avec l'émotion
qui vient avec, en posan
vos propres questions,
ça n'a rien à voir.
- Dans un cadre comme ça,
c'est bien parce qu'en fait,
il y a des gens aussi qui
travaillent ici qui peuvent
aussi vous apporter
des conseils.
- Après un peu plus
de six mois, Fortune Obame vient
de trouver un nouvel emploi.
- Aujourd'hui, je sais plus dans
quelle directionller
qu'au départ, lorsque je suis
rentré dans l'entreprise.
- S'il a grandement apprécié
le temps qu'il a passé
n improbable,
Fortune attend impatiemment
d'emménager un jour dans
un appartement bien à lui.
Ici Raphaël Bouvier-Auclair,-Ce